all right ian
ian where'd you grow up where are you
from originally well
originally from kentucky but kentucky
germany back and forth
oh really and tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents
growing up that's good
um yeah unfortunately
how was your childhood it was it was
brutal
what kind of stuff went on um i was
beaten every single day
my father tried to drown me several
times had such an electrical fence to
make sure it was working
um just anything and everything he could
come up with he was verbal he was
mean he was um the horrible names he
wouldn't smear his stuff all much poop
all over my face
it was just he was just a horrible
person
and you had a mom that was yeah that did
nothing about it and thought that it was
perfectly acceptable to allow him to do
that to me
he had siblings they got the same
treatment
no they helped they um would set me up
and then go
running and crying and they gave me in
trouble well why do you think you got
singled out
um let's see it was the right hair
because he could tell i was gay right
off the bat
um just many different things and i
found out later that he was um
he had homosexual tendencies himself and
i think it was
himself that he saw in me that he feared
the most
so you left home at what age 17. i put a
12-gauge chocolate up his nose and told
me if he
ever touched me again i would blow his
brains out and i meant it i took his
chocolate left
so it was mostly like physical and
verbal abuse
physical verbal emotional everything
yeah but not sexual
he tried but i wasn't going for it and
uh
where'd you go after that i went to the
army oh is that right
did you spend how many years there can
you army um
well seven yeah seven
i um tried to shoot him once he always
took behind him would walk right in
front of me
but i was such a lousy shot and clipped
his air
so yeah i wanted the army to get away
from him and to learn how to shoot
and basically i didn't know how to
because it you know it was a farm i
didn't know how to
make a living i didn't know how to pay
rent i didn't know anything about
anything i needed
some i needed some sort of coverage and
i thought army would be great because it
would also teach me to
you know be able to fight back yeah
and after the army you came back to
where no after the army i went to live
with my grandmother
in germany because i was stationed in
germany and i met her
yeah she as long as my mother was
married to my father she refused to have
anything to do with the family
and eventually made it out to san
francisco yeah um
it was a securities route let's see my
daughter and i were
living in atlanta and um
i use usually i used to spend maybe five
years in the city and then decide okay
it's time to move
and we moved from atlanta to san
francisco i've been here for almost 25
years
i just everything about it just said
okay this is your city when
i first got here there was a woman
standing outside the dollar store with a
big
container of baby powder jumping around
on her head and dancing around like a
ballerina i was like oh this is perfect
this is a city for me and i noticed that
everyone was just a little odd and a
little weird but in an individual way
and that's
really what i loved about city is that
there were so many individuals
it wasn't mass you know everyone had to
be together it had to look the same
and had to go to the same church and
thought processes had to be similar and
everything like that you were allowed to
be an
individual here that's really what
attracted me to the city that's great
and you're happy here for the most part
um
sex has been horrible i haven't had sex
in almost two years because
guys here really suck but other than
that and yeah we got we have
a lot of [ __ ] a lot of people that
just go out of their way to
you know abuse other people and they're
not shy about it they're not uh there's
no shame in their game they're
they're like yeah i'll rob you in a
heartbeat and you know it's like their
inner ass home at the outer [ __ ] and
decided an [ __ ] sandwich is exactly
who they were going to be
so you have you have a daughter and uh
she's in college and
so you were married once or no no no her
mother wanted my sperm
and then decided she wasn't mother
material dropped her off at my doorstep
so you raise your daughter and uh
what do you do for a living i'm an
artist what kind of stuff
i every piece that i create is
completely different
from the previous one so i mean i mean
there is nothing similar in my pieces at
all because i like
i like it to be fresh i like to be
different i like it everything about it
to
not say okay well this looks like his
work
so it just depends on my mood and it
depends on where the piece takes me
while i'm
creating it and working on it because
sometimes the piece decides what it
wants to be before i even know
so it can be anything give me anything
yeah sometimes i'll divide up
a piece of you know of um
canvas and have like four panels doing
different things or sometimes
you know i'll start making like these
little symbols and stuff over here
and maybe some squiggles and stuff over
here and at some point it all just
meshes into something so
you're not unfamiliar with the
tenderloin not at all
and uh where we are now and that's uh
that's because you haven't passed with
drugs
i've had passive drugs the future with
drugs i tried the
clean sober um cult stuff
it didn't work for me i got fat people
were ugly sober
and um quite honestly that the whole
thing just turned me off
so what is your drug today speak crystal
man
yeah that's a common drug now it is you
know i i i went from one drug to the
next to the next
uh crack out here really sucks the rock
the cocaine here the
quality is really bad you get a smidgen
you're always running around trying to
get more and more and more and
you know i refuse to be a hamster on a
wheel i'm way too lazy i don't like
working that's a four-letter word to me
so why would i work to get my job
you know and the thing is you work so
hard running after
stuff to sell and getting the money for
the dog and then you only enjoy the drug
for like a moment
and then you gotta repeat the cycle
again and you know you just you get so
exhausted you never have a place to
sleep you never have a place to live you
never have any friends because you're
constantly chasing this drug
and i decided i was trying to change up
to something different that would mellow
me out and
last longer and speed's done that for me
yeah and you're you're still functioning
you're
you're working or you know you're not
well working is a four-letter word
but you're not living on the street like
no no no i have a place i have a
beautiful place actually yeah
yeah that i can easily afford excellent
have a car and everything
what do you do for money is your art
general yeah they're great
so do you have friends i have a lot of
friends yeah i have really good friends
i tend to um vibe with people who are
similar to me we i don't
i don't rob anybody i don't cheat
anybody i am i don't lie to people i
don't believe there's any
reason to uh most people i can't stand
and honestly if i don't care about you i
don't care what you say about but you
can call me whatever the [ __ ] you want
to
and these are friends that have a
similar mindset we just
you know we're good people and we decide
we're not we're going to remain good
people but at the same time we don't
take any [ __ ]
and um we help each other out we help
other people out and
this is becoming a connection with them
that's growing it's like um
you know it's this thing that is
becoming larger and larger and
we're getting more and more people you
know in our group and friends that's
great
well we have to um kind of conglomerate
together because you know all the
[ __ ] and all the other shits
you know coming out from all directions
we might as well you know become
like this big centerpiece that can get
bigger and bigger bigger and more
stronger
so you mentioned the car that you're
like a misfit
and not so much anymore no well yeah
people still you know it's like the
other day these two guys were whispering
and laughing and pointing i'm like what
first time spotting a [ __ ]
congratulations just spotted one all by
yourself
i mean do you see that the the group of
friends that you have kind of
would fit in the same category they fit
in the same category as i do
and the thing is we're brutally honest
with each other and make each other
crack each other up because
you know i am who i am and they don't
care you know i have my straight friend
otto who's like completely opposite he's
got tattoos all over the place he looks
like a biker dude you know and
you know he's completely serious and
he's one of my best friends and um
you know he's and i said oh yeah that
was being smarter so i was
being a smart ass back and he's like oh
no not you
and we just know each other well enough
that we all click
as friends you know and i used to perv
on him and you know he used to check his
fly every time he saw me coming i'm like
oh you have to check your flight every
time i'm not always looking at your
crotch sometimes i'm looking at your ass
but with your with your past with the
drugs and
tenderloin and all that what kind of
crazy stories that you have to share
oh so many um well the six-year-old boy
walking through the tenderloins three
o'clock in the morning his little
six-year-old boy says is you a [ __ ]
i said well on most days yeah will you
come with me so
i follow him to his sro hey he has me
waiting lobby he goes upstairs to get
his little brother his little brother
comes out
and he turns turns to his brother he
says i brought you a [ __ ]
i was pimped out by a six-year-old his
brother hit him in the arm and said i'm
not gay but
i was just like wow only in the
tenderloin in san francisco would you
find this [ __ ]
um yeah there are also a number of
people that get on our building that
really we're not supposed to have any
guests but there are ways in the
building and it seems like
the people that aren't living in the
building but actually are
is growing in numbers and the people
that used to be living in a building are
kind of gone and we've got like half the
building now
people that are actually residents but
they're living in rooms
and it's funny to me um we get a lot of
people with mental health issues which i
tend to have patience and kindness for
before
you know the most because i understand
you can't help mental health issues
but then we get the people who want to
come in and you know just terrorize and
cause problems and you know we don't
stand for that so
you know it's it's it's a it's an
interesting
dynamic coven you know and how it has
not affected anybody who's using drugs
in fact we have this
idea that you know if you're abusing
drugs then combat won't have anything to
do with you
you know when we don't know anybody
who's sick you know yeah
and it's uh it's funny because you know
every time i walk and
like i was getting a burger today from
its food truck and when was like where's
your mask and i'm like i don't know
where's your ass
i just i hate those masks they're too
high like i can't breathe in them
and just i don't know i i like
how it's divided people and change
people in some ways and now it's brought
people together in other ways and
you know i've noticed that there's a lot
of humanity coming out a lot of kindness
a lot of people going out of their way
to you know
to express that there are good people
out here and i like that side i see in
people
so so being gay and being in san
francisco it's like a
much more accepted thing you don't have
oh please no you're still here no we've
got we've got homophobes
left and right center and i love them
but yeah when they call me [ __ ] i'm like
what you think you're giving me holiday
knows i know i'm a [ __ ] what's your point
come up with you need a thesaurus honey
come up with some new adjectives [ __ ]
i haven't heard that [ __ ] five every
five minutes since i left the house
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
um
not to be ashamed of who i am and not to
be afraid to express who i am
and [ __ ] everybody who doesn't like it
good for you
no i'll fly i'll flip my hair in their
eye in their face if they
mean mugging me and there's a wisp say
[ __ ] underneath their breath and i love
the drive-bys they come by on a
skateboard or on a bicycle and say
something nasty and i can't catch up
with them to beat their ass and i'm like
oh you [ __ ] come back here
what did you [ __ ] call me yeah they
just drive by they go buy a skateboard
or bicycle and then they quickly pedal
off after they said whatever the little
piece was
you know i'm like wow they're just not
they're not man enough to [ __ ] say it
to my face and stand right plant their
legs right in front of me
you know but um yeah it's
it is what it is and i accept people on
their terms and
if they don't accept me i don't give a
[ __ ]
excellent ian thank you so much for
talking with me thank you you're very
interesting
thank you thank you
you